finally after almost ten years a sequel
to 2005 psychonauts is on its way the
game is scheduled to release in July
2018 and is asking for 3.3 million
dollars through crowdfunding the game is
being funded using fig a crowdfunding
platform designed for video games as if
now psychonauts has met about a third of
its goal Psychonauts 2 will be developed
using the Unreal for engine and will
come to xbox one playstation 4 pc mac
and linux Tim Schafer Double Fine's
creative director will be handling a
bulk of the riding along with Erik
Wolpaw the co-author of the first game
the sequel will continue from where the
first one left off Schafer told us in an
interview that Psychonauts 2 is
continuing a story that we always had
planned back when we were doing
psychonauts one where r as was
originally in that game and at a summer
camp training to be a psychonaut now he
is a psychonaut and he's at psychonauts
headquarters the real deal Schafer went
on to say that characters from the first
like Lily Sasha milla and Ford will
return for more information on Double
Fine's upcoming sequel be sure to check
out our lengthy interview with Tim
Schafer